problema número 21 que producto es
equivalente a 4x cuadrada menos 16 entre
2 x y tenemos estas opciones
esto de aquí es lo mismo que tener 4 por
equis cuadrada menos 4 estoy factor
izando el 4 entre 2 x 2 - x y el patrón
que sigue apareciendo aquí es cuadrada
menos b cuadrada así que esto es igual a
4 por x menos 2
por x + 2
x + 2 /
2 - x es igual a menos 1 x
x
- 2 y de esta forma ya puedo eliminar
este elemento de aquí y este elemento de
acá por lo que me queda que es menos 4
por x más 2 y viendo mis opciones menos
4 por x + 2 es ésta la opción de ese es
mi respuesta veamos el siguiente
problema
problema número 22 nos piden realizar
esto el truco aquí es factorizar y
simplificar en lugar de ponerse a
multiplicar todo directamente vamos a
simplificar esas expresiones esta de
aquí puedo ponerla como x
x4 factor hice una equis nada más
aquí abajo no puedo factorizar más queda
x menos tres no lo puedo simplificar más
esto tiene la forma de cuadrada - be
cuadrada esto es lo mismo que tener x
x
+ 3
por x 3
/ estoy acá también lo puedo factorizar
esto lo puedo poner como x 4
por x + 3 y ahora sí puedo simplificar
este x + 4 se va con este este x 3 se va
con este y este x + 3 se va con este
otro así que de todo esto lo único que
me queda es x
que es mi opción b
todo esto para obtener nada más una
equis qué barbaridad siguiente problema
cuál es la forma más simple de toda esta
ecuación vamos a dividir numerador y
denominador entre 5x porque nos va a
quedar x cuadrada 5x y entre 5x cúbica y
pues no nos va a quedar x cuadrada
porque el 5 y leyes se van
+ 20 entre 5 es 4x cuadrado entre x va a
quedar x cuadrado entre yen va a quedar
más 20 en 35 va a quedar 4x entre x se
va de kubica entre que me queda el
cuadrado pero eso no se parece algunas
de las opciones
veamos cómo podemos factorizar lo más
que número x x es la mitad del término
de en medio está 4x james y cuando lo
elevó al cuadrado me da este tercer
elemento pues va a ser x
i
al cuadrado si ustedes hacen esta
multiplicación verán que nos da x
cuadrado a más 4 x 4 ya cuadrado y
viendo las opciones podemos descartar si
bien estas dos no son y los restantes
veo que debo tener un h
así que descartó esta opción
y bueno aquí está la opción que es la
correcta
la opción b siguiente problema problema
número 24 tenemos esa tabla donde nos
están marcando algunos puntos este eje
es de los reales este de los imaginarios
y nos dicen sí y es igual a raíz
cuadrada de menos 1 cual punto muestra
la ubicación de 5 menos 2 y en el plano
el eje x de los reales y el eje y
muestra los imaginarios
es real busco 5 aquí tengo el 5 en mi
parte real y veamos el imaginario en el
eje james que es menos dos menos dos
aquí por lo que mi opción de es el punto
que en el plano indica este número
complejo
5 - 2 y voy a resulta un problema
bastante sencillo siguiente problema
problema número 25 sí y es igual la raíz
cuadrada de menos 1 cuál es el valor de
iu a la cuarta digamos que nunca han
visto en su vida vamos a elevar al
cuadrado ambos lados
si es y la raíz cuadrada de menos 1 por
tener y al cuadrado tendremos
esto al cuadrado me queda igual a menos
1 y ahora vuelvo a elevar al cuadrado
ambos lados me quedan
a la cuarta igual a menos 1 al cuadrado
cualquier número al cuadrado va a quedar
positivo que esto es igual a 1
y esta es mi opción c
siguiente problema
este diagrama el eje de los imaginarios
el eje de los reales nos preguntan qué
número complejo representa el punto de
la gráfica este punto o el número
complejo va a tener una parte real la
parte real es 3 positiva y en una parte
imaginaria que es menos 4 y la parte
imaginaria la ponemos como la y menos 4
y esta es mi opción c y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo